hello my name is sean kimbrough from
north carolina
uh central university in durham north
carolina
and i want to first thank the organizers
for inviting me to share with you some
of my lab's
efforts to solve or at least address or
understand
cancer health disparities
the one aspect that you must appreciate
when you think about
cancer health disparities is understand
that
what the problem really is or at least
understand what the problem looks like
within the parameters of your
investigation
and so i tell my students a lot of times
that
understand uh exactly uh what you
are aiming to resolve or to solve and
you know the so
what behind that research or that bench
experiment
and so the cancer the american
association for cancer research actually
gave a nice report just recently showing
and describing
the cancer disparities issue with
regards to prostate cancer and breast
cancer as
it as you compare african-american men
and women
respectively to their white counterparts
and you can see clearly there that
you're talking about a hundred and
eleven percent
uh increase in risk of dying from
prostate cancer
in african-american men and 39 percent
higher risk
of dying in black women when it comes to
breast cancer
what's also notable here is that you see
you scroll down
there are various other cancers and a
lot of them have or have a tendency
to have ethnicity tied to them or some
type of
association with a a characteristic or a
phenotype
or a category and so here
when you think about that you need to
ask what are all the pieces that
make up or that lead to um that
cancer disparities and so i always like
to show this idea that
some of the key determinants of health
disparities
are hosts the environment and the
behavior of individuals
and i always as a bench scientist
concentrate and look at that genotype
and i like to start there because of my
training over the years i've appreciated
this idea of environment and behavior
and of course quality of healthcare
and access to healthcare as being
another major contributor
to the disparities we see in mortality
related to prostate and
breast cancer disparities so
for the purpose of this talk we're going
to kind of concentrate on the bottom
half here starting off with the host and
understanding the genotype
and the impact of environment with that
genotyping behavior
without being typing in a little
sprinkle of the environment
into that host and behavior mesh
as it pertains to risk for prostate or
breast cancer
now when we started this a while back we
didn't think back in 2010
2008 we didn't think that it would
uh that it would really lead to this
level of
of a response or or interest
um we realized early
from some preliminary work uh looking at
minor allele frequencies between
populations
that some of the variations between
african-american and european american
when we looked at minor allele
frequencies
turned out to be in their immune related
genes or those that were involved
in immune regulation um and
we realized that wow maybe that's the
difference
in order to explain for some of the
large differences we're seeing
in risk and outcomes so even more
recently
it's been in po it's been suggested that
genetic predisposition in immune
modulators modifiers
uh in in african-americans might
contribute to pro-exact prognosis
and even more recent this idea
of african geographic ancestry
and the evolutionary selection of a
more robust immune response or a
different type of
immune response related to ancestry
might really play a role in the tumor
micro environment especially in breast
cancer and
disease progression well to appreciate
that you have to
understand and respect the fact that
life started in africa
and out of africa human beings migrated
out
into the americas and in doing so you
have to
step back and ask yourself that the most
diverse population
the most diverse genotype excuse me is
actually
in the app those of african descent
or those that are from west africa
and you see some of the newest genomes
are actually in the americas
and europe so with that
you have to also argue that whatever
the human beings were optimized for
genetically in their environment in west
africa that
that optimization would probably be a
little different than that what you
would find in europe
and in the americas
we actually uh addressed this issue uh
in a uh a
and cancer immunology immunological
research 2019 where we were looking at
and
proposed this idea that
your ancestor environment ancestral
environment
um in this case we were looking at
breast
and prostate cancer disparities in
african those of african descent we
realized that the selective
pressures in that environment
would have optimized your immune system
such that
you have been optimized for
that environment and
when you are forced to force migration
to slavery in the slave trade and you
are now
transported from your ancestral
environment
to your non-ancestral environment here
in the americas
then you must ask yourself wow there's
no time for change
some would argue that there was um
a forced selection via the trip
from west africa to the americas
but and during that time you would not
have
received necessarily any uh or you
wouldn't have got any selective pressure
on the genome
but there's this migration
from one environment to another and then
that
change in that new environment the
different
um pressure in that environment
and not having enough time to adjust to
those changes
if you had walked the land bridge leads
you to
kind of appreciate the possibility that
you would have a different innate immune
response or a different immune response
with the different pathogens and that
might increase
the rate of cancer incidence or
aggressiveness and would honestly lead
to
possibly cancer disparities so it's this
framework
that we've kind of um worked with
moving forward early on and trying to
explain
some of the differences that we see with
with regards to the biology
of health disparities of cancer
disparities
so just to get a little idea this is a
real
um short version of a little truncated
version of the
immune system um we're talking about
toe-like receptors
and we're talking about the first
response
simply put in a immune
in the immune response pathogen is
recognized by a todac receptor
those those receptors then transmit a
signal
down through my d88 iraq iv
or through tram and trif in terms of
tlr3
and that communication downstream
adapters and kinases
leads to inflammatory
proteins being released cytokines
and also interferons in the case of
tlr-3 and 7-9
also you could go down the path and of
course end up
and end up at apoptosis
so with appreciation of the pathway
um you can argue uh we're going to
present
i'm going to present today tlr3
as a point of interest irf3
which is an interferon responsive factor
um we'll look at iraq iv and
we'll see a little bit of evidence
related to total and and how that
uh and the variance that might occur in
that that might
impact incidents in disease disease
progression or at least very
risk in terms of african-american men
so the first project that kind of
started this was a very small study very
small study
of african-american women at grady
hospital
in atlanta georgia
while i was at emory university in
conjunction with some of my colleagues
at fox chase and um
university of louisville not the lacres
kid and there
we identified some interesting variants
um that looked like we have had some
promise there was a variant in tlr3
that actually was protective um and
there was a variant in iraq
or um which was relevant
in terms of possible um
increase in risk up to almost five times
greater risk however that wasn't
significant
so the one thing that we we've done uh
we realized
that from that study that that was the
first time we kind of recognized
this tlr-3 genotype or
tlr3 or a total receptor being
relevant in some breast cancer risk of
my uh
african american population and that
actually
was associated with an 82 decrease in
breast cancer risk
uh the iraq four story we followed for a
fair amount of time
it was not it was only significant
with risk under an additive genetic
model
and a keeper trend which was significant
well that was the beginning of
appreciating at least the possible role
of a tlr
or the total receptor pathway in
the development of risk for breast
cancer
or cancers related uh differentially um
i wanna say uh disparate between
african-americans and european americans
we went a little farther next time in
collaboration with camille reagan at fox
chase
the team worked together and we wanted
to apply this a little different
apply the genome uh the host the
genotype with the environment and do it
in such a way just to compare
two african-american populations that
were not in the same
location and with the hopes that maybe
that would get at a little bit
at this idea that it's not just the
genotype we appreciate
the environment as being a key component
of
cumulative risk when it comes to
disparities and disparities in the
mortality
due to breast cancer prostate cancer and
in this case
looking at men of african descent when
we looked at our gene list
uh our snip list and that snip list
to to let you know actually came from um
the observation that some of the snips
that we were interested in were not on
the standard jiwads
at the time the g wise chips at the time
and we made an effort that we would
select those
variants that were 25 differential
between african-american descent
in caucasian or european and when top of
the thousand genomes it was
um
the african genotype versus um
the utah the actual uh european american
group uh from utah in that thousand
genomes
um data set and
when we did that we realized that we had
a unique list
and this list was not on the church and
we took that
that list and we started to apply it
to african american samples and like i
said before
that was the breast cancer sample from
grady hospital and here we're presenting
data from men
of mostly from washington d.c area
versus and men from jamaica
and so what we found was that
trlr's tlr6 totalac receptor 6
also had an increased risk if you had
the variant
one point four times is higher and then
you had tolo
which was protective depending on which
snip you were looking at
it was protective if it was the three
prime etr uh variant or
intron one it was up to 1.5 times
more increase in risk
so we wanted to do something a little
bit different though
um uh camille and
lacris uh kid and camille reagan
actually had a fantastic idea
and they separated out the u.s men from
the jamaican men
and in doing so uh we some observations
were made
we found out that one variant in
in the u.s meant was significant but it
wasn't in another
and here's a case where you had and the
age-adjusted eyes ratio
in u.s men was actually protective
wherein
the jamaican minute was not was not
uh and that was significant what was
also interesting that
uh and that was for iraq iv and then we
went to look at tlr-6 remember
previously
it was um it was uh
it did have it did increase risk however
the increase in risk really was result
from the jamaica men
in which the jamaican had a two-fold
increase in risk with this variant
and we didn't see that in those u.s men
so that kind of brings into the picture
this idea that
location made a difference even though
they were from
the same or similar ancestry
further analysis was done using a
multi-dimensional regression
uh machine learning method to kind of
create or identify rather relationships
and associations
and by using mdr we were able to
identify a synergistic relationship
um with iraq iv and tlr2 implying that
together
they probably have an impact on risk our
numbers were not low enough to
we're not high enough to um
reach a threshold to really confirm that
um but we did
identify of course another uh set that
was redundant so the green is redundancy
and red
is synergistic and oranges in between so
at the end of the day
you can use this that this technique to
look at relationships between iraq iv
and tlr2
modifications to mdr exist
in our available um um
aren't available in the literature as
well but it's interesting that this
relationship that we see here is only
found
in prostate cancer risk for u.s men of
african descent
not in the jamaican
so at the end of that uh we can we would
argue that
it looks like we look like we found a
relationship between iraq
iv and tlr2 as possible um
prostate cancer markers for african
american men of u.s
citizenship or u.s um from the u.s or in
the u.s
however that did not hold up for those
men
from jamaican descent or those men that
are in jamaica
we would argue this is when the
beginning of our arguments that the
tlr-related genes
these to-like receptor genes might
actually be responsible our impact
cell survival proliferation and or
inflammation
so it gets you to another piece now that
we've talked about the environment
how about that behavior um and so
when we start looking at that behavior
we're talking about diet we're talking
about exercise
uh i'm just going to show you one slide
from a paper done in conjunction with
um using the same snip list that we
created way back
and ask the question is there a
relationship between
these snips that are
reflective of a minor allele frequency
difference between african-americans and
european americans
uh is that can you use that snip list to
evaluate the risk
as it relates to waste-to-hip ratio for
example and that this population here is
one percent jamaican so this is not the
u.s population
here we're looking at and what you can
see clearly in the top
half you see the snips and the
associated genes
and their risk as it relates
to being non-obese to being lean
and below in the red box you see that
there's an increase of
risk from three to almost five
um fold increase in risk if you have
a whr
a waist-to-hip ratio greater than 0.9
and these are significant relationships
and associations
so you have to ask yourself now we now
have taken
uh ancestry or a variation
that is related to ancestry
and we now added
a behavior and put those two together
and shown
a increase in risk or a risk associated
with a certain genotype
and so obviously these associations are
associated with obesity
they're suggestive there's a small
population a small study relatively
but it definitely warrants looking
further ahead
in a population of men that are not
obese and obese
of african descent whether it be in the
united states or across
the globe another aspect
recently published um from kamels group
in collaboration with camille reagan
from fox chase is ir3
and the ir3 remember is in that pathway
downstream
from the tlrs that are associated with
viral detection and response
and in doing so we find that ir3
is protective and significantly
associated with being of the protection
of
related to prostate risk overall in that
population
but what's really interesting is that
when you come and you add the history
of their sexually transmitted infections
you find that it holds up even more
that there is a correlation between a
variation in ir3 in the viral pathway
that is correlated to
um is correlated to
the genotype and to their sti
infections and so
we get at the story that the end the day
that
we now have behavior environment
and a genotype related to ancestry
and related in part to environment
where where the the individuals live
are have lived for a couple of
generations
and you find that you have a
relationship
that is truly
just implying a
relocation or a response possibly
to a novel in our environment an
environment that they were not
optimized for originally so it always
leads to this slide where we talk about
geographical ancestry as the original
environment
and then that environment one would have
had to
manage energy differently and in the
pathogen
insult according to that environment so
if you came from
west africa you can imagine you have
heat
you have sunlight and you have pathogen
component
uh to this selection process to the
immune
and and actually the whole individual
the whole genotype
that over time would have been modified
and that modification would be seen in
such things as the nate immune
genes some transporter genes and you
would have
such modulation of the lipid metabolism
glucose metabolism
that would be kind of unique to that
population because of the environment
if you take them out of that environment
and move them to this new environment
now you have this increase of
cardiovascular metabolic diseases
things like asthma you have things like
triple negative breast cancer and
prostate cancer these
these these new uh
problems per se that might be a result
more of
the uh taking someone out of
context you're taking someone out of
their original genetic
or genomic or genotype context
and so i always like to leave something
for people to think about as we as we
talk about
health disparities and genetics and the
biology of health
of health disparities and cancer
disparities in particular is
keep in mind this idea of context
if you take an individual out of a
context where they were optimized
to survive and live and you take them
and you
immediately impose them into another
environment with different behaviors
and different and different political
systems and
different social structures it's kind of
hard to think about how you
translate some of that through
xenographs
mouse models or even cell lines
the idea of taking a variant
and you take that variant and you
identify and then you put it
into let's say you identify a variant in
from an african-american
population you put that into a
european-american
context in terms of a cell line
and now you've got a really a different
question
because that variant would be out of
context and the same thing with the
human beings
you've taken them out of context and not
giving them enough time
to adapt to this new environment and
with the change in society that
that the political and
the and the social changes that have
come along with time
you now have a change of behaviors that
are result not only
of the environment but also the
political environment
and some other parameters that are
related more to
the social and psycho social behavior
including stress and so forth that would
have an impact
on that genotype and thus impact
the disparities another example of
something to think about out of context
or the implications of of ancestry
in conjunction with dr kittle's
laboratory
at city of hope a genetic ancestry
that led to misclassification of a cell
line
designated as african-american for years
also
make sure think about and keep in mind
that the biology of health disparities
is just as important
or at least as a player in this in the
psychosocial
and the behavioral piece as well as the
political ramifications
um to health disparities and so i want
to leave you there
with that thought with some of those
things to think about i need to
acknowledge my collaborators at central
my students
and my um postdocs in the laboratory
susan
and erica um um my friend and
at fox chase camila reagan uh the crease
kid
um also uh shanita jefferson
that and carly our colleagues at the
university of the west indies
um and i want to acknowledge the african
caribbean
cancer consortium for providing
access and and and and sharing
uh being part of a team has been really
um really nice to
be part of a team that has a central
mission
um um at the core
i also want to thank the funding
agencies uh nimhd the national institute
of minority health and health
disparities
and the national cancer institute um
for their support of this study
of these studies over time and so i will
once again thank the administrators and
the
um organizers for inviting me to speak
today
um and i look forward to any questions
or any comments
as we move on thank you very much
i hope it was informative thank you very
much